I hate you.
Can you hear me?
That's terrible.
Sorry.
Okay.
Uh,
my name is Laila Barrett.
Danielle.
My name is Joanna and Murphy
and we've been dating how many years?
Three years.
I'm on three arms.
So we met on online
dating.
Okay.
Stupid.
I like to call it.
So we had arranged to meet at this bar and then I remember she walked in looking
at my phone and she kind of stood in front of me.
So I was like,
my eyes went from her feet all the way up to her face and I was like,
ah,
she's not going to hear anything because she's totally done.
The first time I saw Layla where you were at a bar and we'd been texting each
other back and forth.
I saw her immediately sitting there with her looking at her phone.
So I thought,
okay,
I'm going to,
you know,
blow her away.
Maybe.
We'll see.
So I walked up and I stood in front of her,
so I knew that she would have to look for my feet up to my face.
And um,
your mouth is kind of a nice moment.
I was married before and I left the marriage because I knew that I wanted to be
with a woman.
And um,
it took me like four years before I started dating anyone,
especially with a kid,
you know,
really wanted to be sensitive to my daughter's experience and that it was just
an adjustment.
So she is,
she in Laila have a really good relationship.
It's kind of like tourist kind of the one that's raining Laylas behavior in some
times.
And Toro will be like Layla,
I think when I met her daughter,
that's,
that was a big turning point for me.
And I was like,
if I'm serious about this woman,
I have to be a real adult about,
about the situation because there's a child involved.
I think that she likes that I have a little fire under my belly kind of thing
and she likes my humor to,
um,
my friends tell me that I'm a lot of girl and she knows how to handle me.
MMM.
She's confident.
She's got a little bit of a swagger.
She's got a really good sense of humor
and she's got great tip.
I don't know if that's about her as a person.
That
as far as my personality,
I'm much more saltier than she is reactive.
Then she is.
Join is very calm.
She doesn't get,
she doesn't feed into that emotional,
you know,
hurricanes so to speak.
And in return that that makes me calm down to,
not that I'm a raging lunatic or anything.
I can get myself in a tizzy real fast.
There was
time at a coffee shop and her t wasn't hot and they wouldn't Redo so they were
being shitty and she was pissed,
but she was holding it back because Touro was with us and Layla will not do
anything in front of Torah that or make tour think you know anything less of her
not respect her.
He cut the awesome hot.
Oh yes.
If you'd like us to.
If you like a hot a cup of tea,
you'd have to buy another one.
I said,
oh wow.
I was like,
what?
The red is like
you said that to the wrong girl.
These guys were waiting outside.
I said,
I forgot something.
That's it.
Go ahead.
You know,
beat you up the street up,
reach up the road or wait for me outside of whatever.
I went in there,
I took every cup of coffee I could find,
just kind of picked it up and just started it
actually closing my eyes and like chanting at the same time,
Leland,
and we were kind of teasing it out a little bit before that happened
because I was going to on a trip to New York and I was just,
I'm scared to fly.
It's getting to fly.
And I was really,
I really did.
I was really falling in love with Joanna and I was like,
yeah,
I'm going to just tell her I,
you know,
before I left,
it was very organic and just be like,
listen,
I love you and help you back.
I didn't,
no,
I didn't.
She's not,
she's a funny person,
but she's really not about actually a serious person.
She's going to be so disappointed in me when she realizes that I can't tell a
funny story about her.
Okay.
So I'm sitting in front of my big IMAC computer screen,
video conferencing with my boss.
Obviously
I'm an idiot.
I Wa I was like,
Oh,
let me make one of myself some tea.
All of a sudden I see me,
Layla walking by and only underwear and Joanna is so humiliated or she can do,
I head in her hands and I was like,
oh my God,
just say I am so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Like 50 times a box.
So the next part of the dilemma was like I needed to get back into the bedroom
low being Layla thinks she's going to be stealth,
which she is.
So not
like,
how are we going to deal with that?
So I kind of basic,
you've got in craft position and stuff like walk across and all of a sudden I
see at the bottom of the screen I could see my head like bobbing up and down on
this screen that's I was going to cross.
I mean it was so humiliating,
but it was kind of,
it's kind of funny and pretty.
It's at the same time.
Um,
I,
I chose you because you are the most amazing,
beautiful woman in the world and you
have changed me completely.
I really feel that I am like better still a little bit because of you.
You're so kind and loving.
I am so lucky.
I really am honored and grateful to be apart.
You are the heartbeat of our family.
I love you.
And I just,
it just might be so devastated if we went together.
That's not even an option.
Okay.
I have not
told her enough how much I love her and how much she means to me,
even though she has no idea
and I can't imagine a life without her.
She keeps me honest.
She takes the time to really learn about me and know me and you know,
even though she can be wretched with people,
I love everything about her.
I love her.
Her passion for,
for life and for people and for Torah or love for Torah
means a lot to me.
Yeah.
I think that I have to say anything except that I love you so much and I am
great.